luis talks about the social
ramifications of the internet he argued
that the Internet has been a successful
weapon in the hands of the underdog in
business has made its mark on corporate
culture he suggested that the internet
enables people to skirt roles and that
youth are particularly adaptable to the
technology he took questions at the end
of the program from the audience it's
hosted by Barnes & Noble Union Square in
New York the program is about an hour
Michael Lewis or the most recently of
next the future just happened it seems
that the Internet
makes all kinds of things possible I'm
reminded of that wonderful New Yorker
cartoon of a dog sitting at a computer
terminal and the caption reads on the
internet nobody knows you're a dog
equally so it seems nobody knew that
Marcus Arnold was a teenager posing all
too convincingly as a legal expert and
dispensing advice based on his knowledge
of courtroom TV dramas and a stack of
legal reference books also the young
stock market genius Jonathan Levitt who
could see no reason why he shouldn't
play the market the way the big boys on
Wall Street do Michael Lewis is also the
author of several other books including
the International bestsellers lies poker
and the new new thing he has been the
American editor of the British weekly
the spectator and a senior editor at the
New Republic he is currently a
contributing editor for the New York
Times Magazine and has recently moved
back to Berkeley
after a brief sojourn in Paris please
join me in welcoming Michael Lewis
thank you very much then I was walking
up here to do this television interview
someone from the audience came up to me
very disconcertingly and said there are
two hostile reporters in the second row
scheming on how they're going to get you
so be careful when you get up there and
I won't I'll take your questions but I'd
love it if we were so I said when you
raise your hands at the end where are
you it disappeared some years back and
we just organize myself up here
something's back there was an article in
the in the Washingtonians old
Washingtonian magazine about dating what
it was like to date Washington men and
it was mainly an excuse for Washington
female journalists to download their
experiences and there was one one quote
in that article I could have never been
able to get out of my head and it was it
was not it was anonymously delivered but
I'm almost sure it was Maureen Dowd and
she described her experience on one date
with a Washington man and witness which
she said it went as follows that they
they met they went out for for an hour
straight he talked about nothing but
himself and then after he was finished
talking about himself he said he turned
he turned to her and said well enough
about me let's talk about my book
[Music]
that will give some of the flavor of the
witch which you're about to get from me
we accept it except instead of that line
it's not enough enough about my book
let's talk about my television show but
because because this is going to be the
presentation of the book and a bit of
the TV show that goes with it which is
why we have this box up here the book
and the TV show next which is a began of
BBC productions now is going to air on
A&E as well they were conceived together
in the spirit of a great Lewis family
tradition which is sloth and indolence
the motto on the afternoon of the model
and the Lewis family crests of arms is
do as little as possible in that
unwillingly for it is better to receive
a slight reprimand than to perform an
argument task and when the television
people came to me and told me that they
would do my research I thought my god
I've got this is an opportunity that's
not to be missed
that I've been thinking that when I
finished the new new thing I had stuck
in my craw a nugget of an idea for a
book and in that nugget idea was a
response to the dot-com the collapse of
the dot-com bubble and it was the
feeling that I had conviction that I had
that the dot-com bubble was a subplot
that they were real and enduring changes
underneath the bubble that were much
more important in the bubble and that
would go on and on and on and I wanted
to focus on those and I was interested
in those the biggest thing that I had
noticed over the years the last five or
six years was a shift whether it was a
big shift in in the structure of Wall
Street in capitalism how capital gets
allocated and the big shift was the
creation of this whole new industry
called venture capitals and they
sometimes get venture capitalists
private equity
money that's available for entrepreneurs
to take risk with it was an industry
that was born before them long before
the the internet ever came along but but
it was a tiny backwater of an industry
now there was a in the mid 80s there was
you know maybe a billion dollars a year
in capital available to entrepreneurs in
this country and what happened when the
internet came along was this industry
became an industry came formalized in a
way it never had been before and it
became a fashionable place to work
before really before even before the
real bubble happened in the market and
it seems that knowing intimately this
industry I could see that even after but
after even after we've gone through
everything we've gone through it's still
it's still standing and still standing
for very simple reason that there has
been a complete re-evaluation in the
minds of people who have money to invest
in in the market of the nature of risk
this is kind of a follow on in the stock
market to what Michael Milken had done
in the bond markets in the 1980s when I
had worked on Wall Street and watch this
happen Michael Milken had come into the
bond markets in the 1980s and said said
look there's a fundamental misjudgment
that's taking place
you're there they're clear people and
companies that aren't getting loans
because they're too risky but if you
pull all this risk together if the risk
with the returns more than compensate
for the risk but yeah you'll get a pool
of 10 companies you lend money to six of
them sure we'll go bankrupt but before
the don't go bankrupt will more than
compensate you for the loss of you and
you endure on the other six something
like that logic took hold in the stock
market in the 1990s in in by the summer
I mean the institutional investors the
universities pension funds insurance
companies they came to realize that if
you gave a little sliver of your capital
to a venture capitalists and he did this
thing of pulling the risk you know he
invest in ten companies not one and six
dozen would go bankrupt but but but the
other four would more than make up to
the six that went bankrupt
that over the long-term this was this
was a smart thing to do so effectively
what happened was a real entire
reappraisal of the of the notion of
equity rest now it's a little in this
moment of madness in the market those up
and down this this truth is is masked
that is the fundamental change has taken
place but it still it has occurred if
there is there is a there is out there
even now many many millions billions of
dollars available for people to take
risk with that would have been available
before this interested me because we're
when capital when the structure of
capitalism changes other things change
with it and that was something that kind
of got me interested when the BBC calls
me and says what would you like to like
to do something on the social
consequences of the internet we went
back and forth on the subject and came
to the conclusion that in addition to
the first premise that they were
enduring and real changes occurring in
part because of the internet that had
nothing to do with the bubble the second
premise that it was folly to try to
catalog all of the social consequences
of the Internet interview you can draw
any message you want to rather if you're
us so any social theorist can draw any
message he wants to out of the Internet
it is a very complicated vast world so
instead of doing something so rigorous
as that what we did instead was say look
this is the kind of parallel universe
that is growing up very fast in fact one
of the extraordinary things about it is
how quickly it's been adapted by so many
people and love its view it as an
opportunity for social observation a
kind of prism through which to see the
world and it's this new tool that has
landed on us how we use it tells us an
awful lot about what we want as a people
how it's being used tells you a lot
about just basic human desire the way
the world wants to go so let's see if we
can say something about the way it's
being used
and so that became the sort of the
guiding can see for both television and
book and here is where my great ambition
to once we got into this way my great
ambition to do as little work as
possible to generate my book fell apart
because I found pretty quickly the
television material and book material
are two entirely different things
and and and when you bring the
television cameras into a place they
ruin the place in some way I mean if
that people aren't how they are when the
television cameras aren't there
and so I found that the book actually
ended up having to be quite a bit
different from from the TV series
however the one benefit was that some of
the people who were in the TV series are
in the book are the main characters in
the book and I've got little clips of
them that I can show you so we might as
well exploit that the the book is a
really amina it's hard to describe the
structure the structure is something
like an interline internet travelogue
two series of vignettes are designed to
illustrate what I think are larger
points about this technology and where
this technology where we what we're
using this technology for and where I
suggest we want to go it has been
derisive ly described as a freak show
and I think that's actually kind of fair
the people in the book I use to
illustrate the points probably aren't
typical in their unusual people but but
they're interesting freaks I mean what
they do with the technology tells you
something about the world around them
and that was really the criteria we had
for characters you mind if I sip of coke
as opposed to water which is probably a
violation and Barnes and Noble etiquette
but the
the first thing that was kind of it's
still instantly clear when you go out
and you talk to people about their
attitudes towards the internet is how
wholly identified technology has become
with the idea of progress it is the
world even at this gloomy moment in the
stock markets is an extraordinarily
techno centric place and I would argue
more techno centric and popular in the
popular mind than it was before the
internet went boom a great little story
that illustrates this to me is is what
happened in a in a small town in Ireland
a couple of years ago a look at town we
visited with the cameras as I mentioned
in the book a little town called Ennis
and Ennis was on its way to becoming a
ghost town it was one of these small
charming Irish villages where the people
were getting older and older and drunker
and drunker and and it didn't look like
it was heading anywhere good and and a
few into Ennis came the Irish of cell
phone company an Irish cell phone
company said to Ennis and any other town
in Ireland with the populations under
40,000 people they said if you
demonstrate sufficient enthusiasm for
the internet and what it can do for you
we will give you everyone in the town a
free computer and free internet access
and and designate you Ireland's official
Information Age town a few enthusiastic
locals in Ennis decided this was
something they had to have and so they
set about organizing the 40,000 people
who live in Ennis into a fighting force
to become Ireland's official information
age 10 and they did wild crazy things
they got all the kids in the town out to
form a kind of a pattern with a personal
computer on a football field like a
marching
man and then they brought judges from
the cellphone company the helicopter and
flew them over to show them how and the
judges were late on the day that they
were going to do this and the kids
started to faint from the heat because
it was the dead of summer they would
just pull the kids out but Santa didn't
put new kids in I mean they just showed
that they were they were just they were
just wonderfully engaged with this tent
and the end of story is they won they
became Ireland's official information
age town but punchline was the moment
they won they all looked at each other
and they realized that none of them had
any idea what the internet was or what
it did except for a couple of the judges
who had gone and learned otherwise in
the town they had absolutely no notion
of what they'd won all they knew was
they'd beaten out these other towns to
get the Internet and they knew the
internet was something they were
supposed to have and the internet more
importantly was what something it would
make them bring them into the modern age
and make them the town of the future
instead of the town of the past
well the the the end result was very
strange actually what happened in the
town the old people a lot of them took
their computers and kind of prop them up
on on their mantle pieces like football
trophies without even bothered to plug
in mirrors just sign that they had won
and become the official Information Age
town but the younger people took to it
immediately and so by the time I got
there to kind of look into what was
going with the effects of plugging
40,000 Irish people into the internet it
was the young people had risen to
position the promise previously
unthinkable in the town and they were
that they were classes filled with older
people trying to learn from the younger
people what to do on these computers and
the older people were filled with
stories about how the younger people who
are becoming more influenced and didn't
want to hear their old charming old
Irish stories but this was this sort of
story I think was it is fairly typical I
mean we which we already taken it for
granted
the Internet's part of our lives and it
is our use of it is independent of what
happens to dot-com stop
and that's an important point the I
think what I'd like to do is just talk
give you talk to you about a couple of
these curious microcosms that I think
say something bigger about the world
around them
[Music]
to illustrate sort of what I'm getting
at in the book and for that I will use
this device this old technology the the
the first this first it seemed to me the
most obvious message the internet was
delivering to us was in that is how I
came to think about it was the inter was
trying to tell us things about the what
we the way we were and what we wanted it
was that people whose the world is
filled with with people whose prestige
or authority hinges at least in part
it's not entirely on their privileged
access to information they have
information other people don't have and
people come to them for that information
now they may come to them for more than
that information they come to them for
their expertise the way they manipulate
the information but but the privileged
access to information is for example
what for many years
distinguished Wall Street analysts from
everybody else in the marketplace and we
distinguished in fact all professionals
to some extent and so on it was obvious
the internet was eroding this privileged
access to information that one of the
things that did was make information a
lot of information not freely available
to a lot of people freely available to a
lot of people so it stood to reason that
the people who had depended for the
prestige and the access to the
information would be feeling vulnerable
and on that hunch I spent a lot of time
say wandering around doctors offices
talking to doctors about how they felt
about the Internet and they responded
with extraor
canary hostility because all of a sudden
the patients were getting uppity and
this is the story you hear across this
country that the tone is changing inside
the doctor's office because all of a
sudden the patient has a printout from
the internet which may or may not be
accurate but at least makes the patient
feel he knows something that perhaps
even the doctor does not and inclines
the patient to question the doctors
judgment in a way perhaps he would not
have in the task the the this was
interesting but insufficiently dramatic
for my purposes what I wanted was to
find Michael Lewis as a contributing
writer to the New York Times the
professional who all I needed was a
sharp elbow to the ribs and he would be
in real trouble and this was clearly not
the doctor we're all going to need
doctors and respect doctors for a long
time to come
lawyers however a little more vulnerable
and I had a kind of a personal interest
in this story because I grew up I was
raised by a gentleman lawyer I watched I
grew up in New Orleans New Orleans is
the last place in America to change and
it was the last place to forget it to
learn that gentlemen lawyers had no
place in the world
but I grew up at watching the old family
law firm disintegrate under the
essentially the twin pressures of
democratization and commercialization
and the villain of the piece in my
childhood imagination was a character
named Morris Bart who in the mid 1970s
put a big billboard up beside the
interstate highway that said if you get
run over by a car call me and we'll go
get them you know kind of thing that
that which was unthinkable in the legal
profession someone would advertise their
services even you know even then and and
I had watched just my father's
profession in some way it was good for
the consumer but for my father and his
prestige it was what happened was
horrible that slowly be degraded
and to the point where I had to ask
myself could it get any worse could
could could could the prestige of
lawyers sink any lower what forced you
come along to make us dislike them even
more or question their value even more
and and so I wait I asked if the
Internet has something to tell us about
this and indeed it did in the form of a
15 year old boy in the desert of
California who went on the internet last
fall
last summer looking for answers to his
biology test and found a a website
called ask me calm which is one of many
knowledge sharing websites you go on you
ask the experts a question the experts a
self-appointed but they're judged by the
people who ask the questions and and he
got his answer to his biology questions
and he was went surfing around and
Marcus had always had an interest in the
law in the form of an obsession with
court TV to the point where he felt
himself up kind of an aficionado so he
wanders onto this side and he starts
answering questions he finds the
questions he knows the answers to so he
points himself an expert and on his
profile says that he's not 15 years old
but but well we'll see he explains this
to us but 25 years old he's going to
tell you that he said he was twenty
eight fifty was twenty seven he was 25
years old within weeks he devotes now
devotes themselves to answering these
questions he's got hundreds of clients
who are coming to him for advice and
asking him detailed questions about the
law and he is answering this these out
of his stock of knowledge acquired from
court television he rises through the
rest of ask me calm to the point where
he is about three four or five number
evey very highly ranked in the list of
experts many of whom are actually
practicing attorneys who are out there
looking for business did they meet the
client here and then you know they it's
a kind of a first encounter and then if
the client and Laura get along they move
off line the Lord and then starts
charging for what he's doing
at which point when Marcus gets to a
kind of his elevated status he he starts
to get really serious inquiries from
these people he's been dealing with for
the previous few weeks like will you
come will you help me
can I meet with you will you come and
represent me in court and Marcus
responds by putting the family phone
number on the website saying call me for
further consultations and the family
phone starts to ring all hours now where
we kick in here in the TV showing I
apologize for the little part where I'm
in it it's there the worst part but I'm
you know they have to cut away and show
me asking questions and things but I'm
in a development well is when I walk
into Marcus's life is when Marcus's
mother has just decided
narrowly that she is not going to drive
markets around California to various
courthouses so he can be the
fifteen-year-old Perry Mason was a
close-run thing with her I think it's
for food and so meat markets
everybody equal and that definitely has
a chance of being right up there with
the Wall Street professionals I received
about 943 Questers roughly from all
different people yeah and have you been
able to answer all of them I've only
declined for my whole period and why did
you find that traffic law I'm sorry I
don't know traffic law
you're 50 years old does these people
know that you're 15 you know I was my
first question he says well yeah is
there something legal you're doing you
say yeah I told myself I wouldn't want
somebody to come back here and light
orange jelly me well my son's been
giving me this information you know that
he was not supposed to I don't know when
I first went out there I told everybody
I was like you know 20 roughly about 20
and I won't believe it that I told
everybody I was 15 and it was an outrage
there was it's like no it found himself
a ruin people call you at his house
under talking to him as if he's an adult
and I was saying this was a kid the
legal properties market helps to solve
or far from trivial my husband's in jail
for murder he didn't do it I need to
file some some paper they need to file a
motion I want to follow motion for
dismissal I want to follow a motion for
discovery do you think he does know
we're doing yes very much
very much yes yes because there's a lot
of times that we would watch the court
shows and you come up with the same
suggestions or the same answers like the
attorneys with a gift you have a gift
they're like born with legal knowledge
mm-hmm so when someone asks you a
question did he go find out the answer
no never I knew it you knew it exactly
but how do you do it you don't read
textbooks you don't go to websites and
so on so hey I mean where is this now
it's coming from I don't know sometimes
it's common sense answers most of the
time but it's just like
I rather like watching so many TV shows
about the law is defined you know you
know everything you need to know it's
scary but I just know it is scary I'll
agree with that and when you press the
thing is when I pressed him on this
notion of where this how could you not
know where knowledge comes from now
you've got all this knowledge you say
you were basically born with his
response it was priceless he said
welcome to my brain and it was he was
walking it was like he was inviting me
in to have a nice comfortable you know
seat in living room
the the kids ended up taking over a part
of this book in a way I had not expected
them to it took me a while to figure out
why but then the blogger I spent with
them the clearer it became the first
reason was that that one of the one of
the themes that runs through the book is
that the great what is so seditious
about the Internet is that it enables
people to break rules get around rules
get around the constraint against
practicing law without a license I mean
there are lots of rules to get it ended
and kids are especially teenage boys are
particularly indifferent to the
consequences of breaking rules which
leaves them very suited to go ahead and
do it but there was a the other reason I
think that was maybe a little deeper was
just the relationship between the way
the way that children are especially
adolescents adapt to whatever new thing
comes along is the neuroscientist who I
went to go see at at Stanford named
Robert Sapolsky who did a not terribly
scientific but very interesting study
with rigorous but not real science where
he tried to determine
- why it was that people people cease to
become open to new new things in life he
actually wrote it up in a little piece
in The New Yorker a few years ago and he
found was that at about if you haven't
tried a new kind of food they Japanese
food by the age of twenty five isn't
about a 99% chance you'll never try
again for the rest of your life the same
is true of new kinds of music new
fashions you haven't had a you know a
nose ring before you're 22 years old 99%
chance you won't ever have a nose ring
and the same is also true of new
technologies this it's still puzzled him
why this is he established pretty
concrete free persuasively that this was
the case but he says there is no region
in the brain that neurologists have been
able to identify that is the center of
novelty that degrades with age if it is
too so far as the neurologists are
concerned inexplicable but true kids are
adaptable younger people are more
adaptable than older people and I had
seen the other reason I became I became
increasingly interested in this
youthquake thing was I had seen its
commercial effects in my own life when I
first went to work on Wall Street I was
24 years old I assure you I knew
absolutely nothing about Wall Street or
finance
I mean I'd stumbled into a job wandered
into a big trading floor down down
Salomon Brothers bottom of Manhattan six
months later I knew things that the
bosses didn't know and it were critical
to the business and it was because the
compounded into the business at time
when the computer had wandered into the
business and Finance had was was going
through a period it's actually still
going going through where it's a rapid
technical change rapid financial /
technical change lots of innovation
and in that climate younger people have
a huge advantage partly because they're
not wedded to - to the way old ways of
doing things partly - there are a lot of
time and energy but probably have note
there no vested interest in all ways of
doing things and the phenomena of the 24
year old Wall Street millionaire arises
right out of that right out of that
central fact of rapid innovation on the
trend live in the in the financial
business if that that's why we had the
24 year old millionaire a rise of the
character and the culture in the mid-80s
because computers hit the trading floor
I really think that's why I never
thought that 24 might there might be one
day where 24 was considered old in the
financial business I never thought that
a teenager we have something more to
tell us about financial world until I
met Jonathan lebed and I'm going to
first show you a clip of John a little
bit because we actually explain his
story a little bit in this clip and then
we will draw the moral of the story
sorry about this
this gives us this skew this whole thing
a flavor of a corporate presentation
where it all becomes part about the
slide and whether they work rather than
so you're saying anything is interesting
Cedar Grove is one of those New Jersey
suburbs defined mainly by the fact that
is not the big city and not a place
where big things happened that's
Jonathan Lebed just after his 13th
birthday Jonathan went onto the Internet
armed only with a small piggyback in an
account on America Online he made eight
hundred thousand dollars in the stock
market the friends at school know that
the kind of lighting that you may not
really and if I would have told them
they wouldn't believe me anyway so he
didn't tell anybody but player message
did your parents out yeah he started
studying companies in and once he got on
the internet he did you know really
started companies find out about them
profits accenting everything and that's
what he got really interested in like 12
13 years old this is all this basically
of the most active stocks of the day
Jonathan woke up very early before a
school bought stock in a company he
liked then plastered the internet with
hundreds of messages telling other
people to buy the same stock he's tired
he did this the stock prices rocketed up
allowing Jonathan to sell at a profit
because biggest one-day gain was seventy
four thousand dollars he became in
effect an influential expert he would
say hey I found out about this about the
company even close it you know certain
certain things that I didn't even
realize he knows don't know anything
about different companies know a lot
more about a company and he knows he
just knows the informational you know a
lot more the incident than you like like
me I was always a newspaper um stop
person can you tell her 11 year old with
a straight face but if they stuck at it
for a few years it by the age of say
fourteen and fifteen that they could be
playing on a level playing field with
Wall Street professionals
I definitely would I think that with the
technology we have today with the
internet it makes everybody equal and
that they definitely would have the
chance of being right up there with the
wall street professionals
I found that Jonathan Lavetta had a lot
to teach me but he couldn't do it in the
flash and it was extraordinarily
frustrating because I spent quite a bit
of time with him before I bothered him
with the television cameras to go in
with the television cameras and try to
get his character on TV because in the
flesh you saw that was his fourth coming
as he ever is you know there was many
syllables would come out of his mouth in
you know in an hour and and just nothing
came he had this extraordinary
experience which culminated with the FCC
sending subpoenas to his parents telling
them that the Magellan was doing was
illegal we'll come to that and he had
nothing to say about it and I just I
discovered that the the reason I was
unable to get to Jonathan in the flesh
was the Jonathan the flesh didn't really
know who he was but when he got on the
internet he came along and when I
emailed him and asked him about himself
and his experiences I got back some of
the more shrewd and persuasive
dissections of the ways of Wall Street
that I have ever read and give you a
flavor of that by his lawyer by the way
he had the same problem and and when he
took Jonathan's case on founding he
couldn't get anything out of out of
Jonathan so he asked something to
explain exactly what he thought of the
stock market and Jonathan wrote him an
email
having said nothing about it the next
day an email arrives and the lawyers
office and it starts as follows
I was going over some old press releases
about different companies the best
performing stock in 1999 on the Nasdaq
was Qualcomm Qualcomm was up around
2,000 percent for the year on December
29th of last year even after Qualcomm
run from 25 to 500 Paine Webber analysts
Walter P key came out and issued a Buy
rating on Qualcomm with a target price
of 1000 Qualcomm finished the day up 156
to 662 there was nothing fundamentally
that would make Qualcomm worth 1000
there is no way that a company with
sales under 4 billion should be worth
hundreds of billions of dollars in the
weeks to come
Qualcomm continued strong going as high
as 800 in early January
Qualcomm was being driven not by
fundamentals but simply by the fact that
a high price target was issued and many
people were trading it Qualcomm now has
fallen from 800 to under 300 it is no
longer the hot play with all the
attention many people were able to
successfully time Qualcomm and make a
lot of money the ones who had bad timing
lost a lot of money people who trade
stocks trade based on what they feel
will move and they can trade for a
profit nobody makes investment decisions
based on reading financial filings
whether a company is making millions or
losing millions it has no impact on the
price of a stock whether it's whether it
is analysts brokers advisers internet
traders or the companies themselves
everybody is manipulating the market if
it wasn't for everybody manipulating the
market there wouldn't be a stock market
at all out of the mouths of AIDS
Jonathan as I said expressed of you both
in the market and in print that is
almost diametrically opposed to the
security laws of these culture of this
country
and as a result he got these subpoenas
instead accused him of broadening talk
about market manipulation the FCC in the
first place couldn't believe it actually
they were the kid who was doing this
they thought the kid was the front for
the father but then they met the father
and and realized that the world is
stranger than they knew right and so
after I met John and heard his his sort
of view of the world I went to go see
the SEC the in fact chairman of the SEC
lost 11 and you know they're journalists
I have done journalism where the intent
was hostile right from the start so I
know what that feels like when you walk
into someone's office meaning to do them
harm or come to someone's lecture
meaning to do them harm and and and you
have malice in your heart and you and
you proceed accordingly you have good
reason but but but actually by the time
I knew only so much about the case by
the time but when I went to go visit off
11 and I honestly thought that when I
went to go see the chairman of the SEC
he'd explained to me why it was I
couldn't see the difference between or
Jonathan and Jonathan Queen see the
difference between what he did buying
stocks and praising them on the internet
trying to persuade other people to do
what he had done and what Wall Street
professionals did it seemed to me it
seemed to me it would be no important
distinction between the two and I
thought we were going to have a jolly
meeting and at the end of the jolly mean
I come away disabuse of my of my notions
but instead it got it became a very
hostile meeting a very unpleasant
meeting and the malice filled my heart
only after I left him but but but he
couldn't not only could they not explain
in a way I could understand the
difference between what the kid did
with the Wall Street pros did who after
all the kid was just a fee everything
the kid knew about the markets he knew
from being on the internet from watching
pros on the Internet
he couldn't he couldn't explain to me in
a way I completely understood having
been with Jonathan why it should feel
wrong to do what Jonathan had done and
and I realized from Jonathan that we had
just very different views about the need
for regulation in a stock market and
that what Jonathan was expressing was
possibly a very contemporary view that
the SEC the securities regulations
countries premise on the notion that
people need special protection in
matters financial that they're
especially vulnerable to being abused by
people who deal with them more so than
in other commercial dealings so that
it's not enough to protect against
simple fraud I mean everyone would agree
but if Jonathan lebed had gone on the
internet and dummied up a press release
from a CEO from a company saying we're
going to merge with another company that
that would be fraud and that should be
prosecuted that wasn't what he was doing
what he was doing is plastering the
Internet with extremely absurdly
enthusiastic endorsements for the
companies he bought he sounded like
crazy yet you know getting rid of
refrigerators and and I couldn't
understand how that was different from
even what from what people do in
ordinary commercial life and it turned
out neither could he because as he as he
wrote explaining where he got his
technique for promoting companies every
morning I watched shop at home a show on
cable television that sells such
products as baseball cards coins and
electronics Don West the host of the
show always says things like this is one
of the best deals in the history of shop
at home this is a no brainer folks this
is an absolutely unbelievable deal
congratulations to everybody who got in
on this folks you got to get online this
is just a gift I can't believe this
there is Jonathan Wright's absolutely
nothing wrong with him making
such as those as long as he isn't lying
about the condition of a baseball card
or lying about how large television is
he isn't committing any kind of crime
the same thing applies to people who
discuss stocks notice struck me as very
mature attitude that met and in fact if
a 14-year old boy can get on the
internet and figure it out for himself
so easily then maybe we have in fact
arrived at a time where we Americans who
after all are more obsessed about money
and more knowledgeable on money and any
people in the history of the planet
maybe we don't need special protection
in this sphere and that maybe the people
who actually see FCC by we had trouble
finding actual victims people who come
forward and say I lost money because I
believed when this kid wrote by fire
Tech it's going up but that was a good
piece of advice but in fact what was
happening was a lot of people just as
savvy as Jonathan may be slightly less
savage elephant but in the same
wavelength saw that someone was coming
into the market making a noise about a
company that no one had made noise about
in a while that possibly had a good
story to tell and they joined the the
enthusiasm thinking that this was a wave
they could catch much as much as Wall
Street analyst did so Jonathan I felt
had something to tell us about possibly
rethinking regulation of the securities
markets he he also the story to me the
story had many levels and the more I got
into it the more it became clear that
the financial side of it though
extremely interesting was less
interesting than the interpersonal side
of all and that what Jonathan really
showed was how fragile the social order
is and how fragile the chain of command
is in a life of a boy in the New Jersey
suburbs because the minute Jonathan
became a rich stock market trailer his
life in Cedar Grove New Jersey was
turned upside down
he began became the Warren Buffett of
Cedar Grove New Jersey when he went to
school the teachers all came up to him
in the hallways and said what should I
buy today he was pulled out of in the
middle of tests by teachers to examine
lists of stock the teacher was going to
go by online on the library computers
his looking for advice from this kid all
of his fellow students who were
interested in sorting and there were a
lot when he came to school would ask him
what was that company that he'd bought
this morning and was promoted so they
could get it on to one of the students
said fifth period study hall was like a
little Wall Street because this serious
study hall was held in the library where
all the computers were and they were all
online and the kids instead of studying
with go to computers and trade their
accounts there were families in Cedar
Grove that gave their savings to the kid
in the family because he was doing so
well in the market thanks to Jonathan
Moore profoundly inside the lavet
household the chain of command was
averted this wasn't terribly hard to do
but it was it never lacked it happened
the father in some weird way became the
Son and the son became the father that
that it made me realize seeing is that
you seeing this what it would happen in
the house where the father came in some
strength way at the mercy of the son in
his success it put a fine point on I
think a general truth about the
technology about rapid technical change
generally that the the effect was the
effect it has on a family to move to
another question it was that the family
felt like newly arrived immigrants from
China in San Francisco where the kids
all of a sudden spoke learn to learn to
speak English and the parents didn't
know how and so the parents became
completely at the mercy of the kids and
so the effective of the internet was
kind of transformed this family into an
immigrant family and you couldn't help
but wonder if in some small way this was
happening across the country where kids
going online acquiring information that
previously had been either available
only to the grown up or to no one
and using it to essentially seize status
and power inside the family the the
final point about Jonathan that was true
of all the kids I met on this little
journey I took was the way he used the
Internet to find out who he was who he
was was a person who was extremely adept
and a curious capacity to see the world
in the game and to wait like a Wall
Street trader I mean this boy could be a
Wall Street trader he had an ability to
deceive to not let his emotions enter
into things and see the pros and the
cons of any different any particular
decision and act accordingly and he had
he had this ability but he didn't find
it in himself until he went on the
internet and I think that the fact that
in a disguised who he was to the world
enabled him to play this adult world
this adult role awakened something in
him he found that what we know we're
looking at it he didn't particularly
like the hand he was dealt in the flesh
that he wasn't particularly happy with
life out there in the real world this
life he created for himself on the
internet was far more appealing and so
that in a way it was a great moment of
trials when Jonathan's is a one moment I
could i defined where Jonathan in the
flesh came together with Jonathan on the
web and I read you this passage because
I feel like this was supposed to be a
reading right I should read you
something that I wrote not not some 15
year old boys wrote I've just been shown
I've just been shown one of Jonathan's
bombastic email message postings on the
internet which is just email insane
stuff by this by exclamation points
everywhere big caps and I'm in his
living room with with Jonathan and a
family and the lawyer and I turn to him
and the author of that and dozens more
like it now cell sat dully at the end of
the family's dining room table and
watched the Washington's parents take
potshots at each other in their
government
there wasn't an exclamation point in it
clearly just trying to get his client
interested in the conversation for the
benefit of an outside observer
Jonathan's lawyer who had been watching
in silence what was to him a familiar
scene recalled the day the sec handed
over Jonathan's name and address to the
press the lawyer had called to tell the
lebed's
that they should stay inside and not
have anything to do with journalists and
certainly not answer any questions on
cue journalists from just about every
place on the planet over and the lebed's
front yard news trucks fat guys with
huge cameras screeching women in
sneakers Connie called Greg and told him
she wanted to move away from Cedar Grove
to a place where no one knew them their
11 year old daughter Dana burst into
tears and ran out the back door with the
promise that she was going to live the
rest of her life at a friend's house
Greg hollered Greg hollered expletives
into the phone and hopped on a
high-speed train to triple bypass
Jonathan was the only one who remained
calm while Connie smoked the family
lawyer whose card was now glued on the
wall to the wall over the phone Jonathan
walked out the front door and presented
himself to the mob Jeff I got to do the
accent I'm afraid Jonathan
Connie whale Kevin said not to go out
there where you going what's going on
there Moreno shouted Jonathan's outside
holding a press conference
[Music]
that's just what he'd done he strolled
out the front door and told the
reporters they would talk to them on the
condition that they mentioned the name
of his new website in their newspapers
Connie Nelson I'm inside Yellin Jonathan
Jonathan come in come in Kevin says come
in and he's not coming in so I take the
phone out to the front I make him talk
to Kevin Kevin yelled at him to get in
the house it was so fun that day
Jonathan said then juk ducked back
inside his shell thank you very much and
I'm happy to take questions from anybody
and by the way c-span has taped is
taping this and they asked it if you
have a question that you go to this
microphone here at the center and
present it to a national audience so
start in the back to encourage a great
you don't look like a hospital
journalist neither the Internet's
supposed to be a global phenomenon but
everything you've talked about so far
today suspect most of stuff in your book
is about how the Internet has affected
the u.s. why do you think that these
general social influences as well as the
things you talked on your previous book
have happened in the United States
rather than in other countries if this
is one of those questions that I'm going
to lay awake at night tonight thinking
of the answer because it's a good it's a
good question in the book is not it
isn't actually as wholly American as I
present it is mostly American but in the
TV show because the BBC co-produced it
was not at all I mean and it was it was
true that you wander around it this
isn't just America that scandal highest
in trace of Internet usage or in
Scandinavia much higher than here
and there's awful lot of trouble made by
teenagers in Scandinavia to linus
torvalds
just for starters but it is clearly the
mania hat this is the capital the mania
and it's the capital of the trouble make
a lot of the trouble making and you know
I think partly it's partly why the kids
who I ran across who caused the trouble
all lived in kind of unrooted places
they were all they were all in places
where the real their immediate physical
environment was not terribly appealing
to them did not satisfy them in some way
they weren't they weren't living in
fancy apartments on the Upper East Side
they were there was them they lacked
stimulation
and their actual in their in their
immediate lives I think that America
specializes in putting people in sensory
deprivation tanks and and and especially
kids suburban kids and so that may be
part of the reason to keep the kids came
from here America also is the home to
venture capital and if you want to know
why the whole calm thing start here is
because the venture capital the global
capital a venture capital is Silicon
Valley but it's spreading I mean I think
that this is a matter of amount of time
before the rest of the world
Louis world is catching up to America in
terms of internet usage is it's a matter
of time before this becomes more uniform
global experience that's a struggling
attempts to answer what is a really much
better question
a hunter loose ah I must complain that I
haven't read it's the bogus and you
haven't came out today and I have read
though the last two reviews of the Queen
inside here tanks and is not that I am
buying into your into your reviews but I
want to touch you on another issue and
that is don't you think that the the
cases that you have highlighted or
basically you bookish about these two
cases and trying to draw more general
conclusions just erase people engineer
tanks compares you to haggle I don't
think that you ever thought that hazard
to becoming the heckler experiences but
my point is to us exchange those are
more anecdotal cases and we still live
in a world dominated by big corporations
and let me quickly elaborate my case if
someone and I don't know about you guys
but if someone knows about Jonathan
Leavitt a in say Nevada or even New York
New Jersey is because it was news in the
Indian D in the establish media might be
that that media is combining with the
Internet and that you click your the
internet and what shows up or what the
media is is a thousand and the big media
in a way don't you think that we live
now more in error in a world where as
much as in the fifties is in our mention
about the military-industrial complex
and now it's a techno media
complex in which yes these cases
happened but where do they get their
their their their their knowledge
through the established powers and how
they they became famous well through
established powers if you I was cut it
we're not you're seeking to become a
question is becoming a very eloquent
speech no my question my question here
you do point is yes these cases show
that a big revolution has happened but
what extent has it been a revolution and
not a relation of the concentration of
power even if us do a lot of surfing and
buy airline tickets and using that oh
and discover new guys called Expedia or
Travelocity well do a little bit more of
research and see who are the owners of
them no look this isn't you you're
exaggerating the points I'm making to
make them seem ridiculous but but when
they went to reality to get hurt oh I'd
respect you very much no no I wasn't
saying you think I'm ridiculous because
I know anything here here right or let
me correct the record only one of the
reviews in the New York Times is bad who
you talked about that a few it lives but
but look the argument I make in the book
is slightly more subtle than big power
power isn't centralized anymore it's now
little guys who are in charge that's not
that's not that's not an argument any
way would make it a straight face what I
do want you is that the way capitalism
moves forward is in the kind of dialogue
between insiders and Outsiders big
corporate power I agree it exists still
AOL is the great example on the Internet
it's the corporate hub of the internet
now and and little guys who challenged
them and the technology new technology
is often a weapon immediately first
blush in the hands of the little guys
the argument I make is that the dialogue
between those two has become more
intense
they've been shoved closer together
little guys can cause
immediate trouble for big guys then they
could in the 1950s and I think that's
true now
the big guys don't just sit there and
get rolled over there's this process of
the little guy creating trouble for the
big guy the big guy responded usually by
assimilating
the changes that the little guy is
proposing and then squashing the little
guy what's happened where we are now in
the Internet where it's a revolution as
well as words a I should be more I
should be a little more reticent to you
than I am perhaps in print but where we
are now in the revolution is towards the
end of a cycle where this thing happened
in the corporate sphere anyway it was
hugely destabilizing to big corporations
there were lots of little companies that
were created that if big guys didn't
respond in any way would have been a
huge threat big guys but the big guys
did respond
Mika's Microsoft brought squashed
Netscape you know I mean a lot there
lots of stories like that and but the
way the big guys responded was become a
little bit more like the little guys
that that we have a new there's a new
corporate religion in America today that
you can argue has a lot to do with what
happened the last five years and the
corporate religion is one less hierarchy
within the company to the experiment I'm
going to have about two degress into it
my wife once interviewed a porn star on
television and he was trying to make his
case and he said a give and a and a and
I know excited was one and to the v of
the big guys now have a whole new
attitude towards innovation that there
is a whole new there is a higher
receptivity to innovation within big
corporations and entrepreneurship within
big corporations because partly because
they invented them and the Internet
itself has been assimilated by big
corporations yes it's true there's too
much power in too few hands and there
always will be but the process of social
change I think it has changed
that dialogue that forces it between the
little guys that did God
big guys today aren't exactly the same
as the big guys in the 1950s is it
different their subtle differences but
important difference between them this
is the last question okay since we're at
seemingly of course at the end of the
cycle would you say mobile commerce
would be the next step
I mean logical set since you're saying
of course a lot of teenagers in
Scandinavia of course there's a lot of
internet access and of course we also
see a revolution with the wireless
handsets PDAs etc would you see would
you see that in the future being the
next step for another revolution you
know I think I've made a living as an
author raising the hopes of my readers
that if they open my books they will
actually get some practical advice that
will be of use to them from them and
then I will know what's going to happen
next
Lars Pope came out everybody's always
asking me for stock tips and if there's
one message in liars poker is that I'm
the last person you should ask you know
what to do with your money but but I
don't think I'm terribly equipped to
answer questions about where technology
is going I think I do think that it's
safe to say the internet will be
ubiquitous and much faster how long it
takes I don't know it's safe to say that
some people can find very useful to have
mobile phones that are connected the
Internet all the time but you know I I
don't I don't want to be pinned down on
any kind of practical useful question
yes it's not what I do I do for valla
day anyway thank you very much Michael
Lewis is a contributing writer to the
New York Times Magazine a columnist for
Bloomberg and a visiting fellow at the
University of California at Berkeley
he's also written for The New Yorker
Slade in foreign affairs his book is
published by WW Norton & Company and to
learn more about the book go to w Norton
com